jeopardy used ronnie the limo driver and
a clue
now i know my world howard what does
that mean
it means
everything is off i mean ronnie the limo
driver's a clue on jeopardy that's what
it means did the the somebody answer it
oh yeah of course ronnie the limo driver
the biggest star on the planet
i never in my life could have predicted
that ronnie the limo driver would be a
clue
on jeopardy i mean i was gonna say when
he was up there driving you did you look
at the back of his head and said one day
he's gonna be a clue on jeopardy
i looked at the back of his head and i
went does he have dandruff
from queens for 600.
this shock jock and self-proclaimed king
of all media was born in queens his pal
ronnie the limo driver was a longtime
resident
mallory who is howard stern yes
ronnie did you know you were mentioned
on jeopardy they put it up on twitter
and it said you were on jeopardy and
what the [ __ ] are they talking about
and then uh
i i looked it i looked it uh some guy
then posted it
like he took a picture of the tv
and i saw it and then
you know in new york it airs at seven
o'clock here it's it doesn't air until
seven o'clock our time
so i got to see it you know when they
when they ran it wouldn't it be cool now
if every episode there was a reference
to ronnie in it i mean i don't know i
think that'd be fun how about this one
ronnie this driver and grandfather
spends his free time retweeting nude
photos of women
this senior citizen thinks mike perlman
messed with his bagel
that's right
there you go a lot of clues there man
here's a jeopardy question
this driver to the stars
once pulled a really hard [ __ ] out of
his ass with his bare hands oh my god
yeah oh that was a day to remember boy
you talk about crying holy [ __ ] he did
great
tears that day wow
alex trebek must have been spinning in
his grave he was sitting there in his
grave saying i died in time